with a geopolitical landscape in a flux
what is Europe's roadmap for the future
does it need to rethink its collective
security and defence policy and by doing
so will it then create an impenetrable
EU fortress time to take a closer look
we're here at a belgian army base in
Leopold Berg to talk to Colonel settle
to learn a little bit more about what
armies do and the security challenges
facing Europe cabeza Leopold's burgers
also when eaten battle group trains in
2013 the first time in almost five to 10
years Europe talked about defense and
they said defense matters and they were
looking at three different strengths we
were looking at strengths as a
visibility capacity and Industry Europe
still lacks and strategic capacities the
origins of a collective defence policy
date as far back the 1940s it started
with the Treaty of Brussels signed in
1948 and amended in 1954 in Paris it was
implemented by a new military
organization the Western European Union
the most important idea of the treaty
was an article 5 the idea of coming to
the aid of another under attack
following the cold warned Balkan
conflicts European leaders took a
decisive step to develop collective
capabilities capabilities that included
the creation of a credible military
force but it wasn't until the 2009
lisbon treaty that things really kicked
off the coleman security and defence
policy or csdp was created with
solidarity serving as an impetus for
joint action the treaty created an
umbrella organization the European
external action service under the reins
of an already existing Hugh high
representative for security and foreign
affairs the post is currently held by
federica mogherini the EAS includes a
military staff objective in all these
trends and lines of action there's to
make best use of member states resources
the most effective use for member states
and for European Union in the context of
their contributions one concrete step is
Europe copes with five EU members and
based in Strasburg but it's not the only
one missions under the csdp are
widespread you for is in but a label for
the European Union force so far some 15
civilian and military peacekeeping
missions with soldiers from various
member states have been completed the
same amount are currently underway in
say for example Ukraine Marley and the
Palestinian territories the csdp only
allows the financing of civilian
missions military defense operations
have to be financed by member states
their contributions to a defense budget
of saul's 190 billion euros but the
problem of the 28 countries collective
member states see defense as a matter of
strict national sovereignty so there's
duplication of equipment resources in
personnel but the european parliament
and in particular Subcommittee on
security defense is pushing for more
oversight of the csdp and a calling for
an EU defence equipment market could
that make a difference in the future
well there's definitely one thing that
could make a huge difference and it's
something that has been discussed for
decades has its time finally come of
course I'm talking about the idea
bandied around by EU Federalist the idea
of an EU army the thing is the EU
actually has an army of sorts
well actually when you look at the
battle groups on the battle groups from
a military perspective they are ready to
go it's just a rapid reaction for crisis
and unexpected crisis so you have to
have those conditions because this is
the concept of using a battle group
first of all you don't have 0 member
states don't necessarily have the same
sensitivity the same feeling about the
importance of the crisis and on the
other side it's a it's an issue of
financial means and that's always been
it's problem power and money struggles
between member states have left them
unused besides their function is already
served by NATO and UN peacekeeping
troops so it begs the question whether
an EU army could ever really exist it's
like firemen I mean if you if you don't
have fire would you stop with your
having an training fight male so you
have always to be ready there's an old
motto that says united we stand divided
before since its inception the European
project has been about one thing
bringing its policies and people
together with common threats they need
common solutions if they're ever to
break new ground on foreign and security
policy